♪♪
-Here's how the game works.
-Matthew and Johnny,
here you go.
Here's yours.
-There's yours.
Matthew, for you. Johnny.
-Johnny, there's yours.
-Don't embarrass me.
-We'll try.
-This is national television.
-It's hard not to.
-This is for you right here.
-I'm going to read you
a question about your dad,
and I want you to write down
what you think the answer is.
Rob, you'll write down
the real answer.
-All right.
-Okay.
Then, you'll reveal your answers
to see which son is really
the Best Son. Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
First question is, "If Rob
could only watch one movie
for the rest of his life,
what would it be?"
I'm not looking.
I want to be surprised.
[ Drums playing softly ]
Don't look Matthew.
Don't look.
[ Laughter ]
-Was he peeking?
-Matthew was peeking, I think.
-So, he should...
-No, it's all right, we'll see.
We'll see what happens.
Here we go.
You ready?
Matthew, have you written it?
-Yeah, yeah.
-All right, here we go.
Matthew, reveal,
what movie would it be?
[ Drumroll]
"Goodfellas."
Very interesting, okay.
John Owen?
"Goodfellas"?
Rob Lowe?
[ Loud drumroll ]
Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Music plays ]
[ As Ray Liotta ] Karen!
-Karen!
Karen!
-You know what kind of people
go to j-- [ laughs ]
-That's the best.
-Best movie.
-I think we watched that
when we were probably
a little too young.
-Yeah.
-All right, yeah yeah yeah.
Let's not get into details
about when you watched that.
That's great.
I love that movie.
-Best movie ever!
-It's so good.
-All right, next question is,
"If a genie gave Rob one wish,
what would he wish for?"
-Johnny's laughing.
[ Drums playing softly ]
He's laughing.
He already is writing something.
Matthew's stumped.
He's not sure what it is.
-One wish?
-"If a genie gave Rob one wish,
what would he wish for?"
[ Drums playing softly ]
-That's so esoteric!
-Hey man, it's 2017.
-Okay, um...
[ Laughter ]
-Genies give one wish now.
[ Drums playing softly ]
All right, here we go.
Everyone's still writing.
No drawing pictures, either.
Ready?
Matthew, still writing.
What did you write down?
-"Live to be 100."
[ Drumroll ]
-"Live to be 100!"
Interesting.
What did you say, Johnny?
-"More wishes."
-Ah, "More wishes!"
[ Laughter ]
That's a good secret one.
-I'm going with Matthew Lowe,
"Eternal life"!
-Wow, "Eternal life"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Music plays ]
Matthew, eternal life!
[ Laughs ]
-I should --
But John Owen's smarter
than all of us,
and he picks the one
you should pick.
-That's like cheating, though.
-Maybe the loophole wasn't
the way to go.
-Yeah, but it's good!
-No, you went with the loophole.
What were you about to...
-I was going to say --
I questioned it at first.
I thought maybe this is immoral,
but I think that it's allowed.
-Matthew's in the lead.
Matthew's in the lead
for being Best Son.
Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-Damn it!
-Next question.
"What makes Rob laugh
the hardest?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ] "What makes
Rob laugh the hardest?"
All right, guys.
[ Drums playing softly ]
What makes Dad laugh
the hardest?
-Oh, my gosh.
-Like, think more of a giggle,
closer to a guffaw, maybe.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't think he even knows.
-Like a... [ laughs ]
That type of fun laugh where...
-Uh...
...it's, like, out-of-breath
laughing like, "Wow."
-Okay.
-Crying, tears are coming out.
-Like, "That makes me laugh
so hard, oh, man.
That was really funny."
Could be a comedy,
could be something physical,
could be an impression,
could be anything, really.
Matthew, you're good?
-Yeah, I think.
We'll see.
-All right, that's good.
Matthew, don't look
at your brother's thing!
-I'm already done.
-All right.
-Is he cheating?
-All right, ready?
Here we go.
Matthew, what did
you write down?
-"Funny animals."
-"Funny animals"!
-He's going the safe route.
-Okay, "Funny animals."
[ Drumroll ]
-"My friends."
-Your friends?
-Yeah.
He's always laughing
at my friends.
-I do, that is true.
-His friends are funny?
Okay, but what did you say?
Is it not his friends?
[ Loud drumroll ]
-Doctor --
Okay, but I showed you that
so I should maybe get
a point for this.
-"Steve Brule"?
-Steve Brule!
Are we talking about John...
-Right?
-I showed how funny he is.
-Dead silence in the audience.
-John C. Reilly...
[ Laughter ]
-Dead silence.
Everyone like, "We don't know
John C. Reilly."
-John C. Reilly is
Dr. Steve Brule.
-The best thing ever.
-It might be one of
the funniest things
I've ever seen.
-I'm not crazy, right?
-Yeah, Tim and Eric.
Yeah, absolutely it's great.
-Yes.
-Okay, good, all right.
-But in fairness,
who showed you that?
-They turned me onto it.
-Well, they?
-They're my barometers
of anything that's actually...
-Who in particular showed you?
-Which one specifically?
-Matthew and Johnny.
-No, it was me!
[ Laughter ]
-That's shady.
-Yeah, it's a little shady.
But we talked to the judge,
and we're going to give Johnny
one point for that,
so it's a tie game.
-Yay!
[ Music plays ]
-This is the last --
the last question.
-All right.
-The last question.
This is to see
who is the Best Son.
This is worth 1,000 points.
[ Laughter ]
-1,000?
-This one's worth 1,000 points.
-Worth 1,000?
-Whoever wins this one wins.
-Well, do you want to
try for it, too?
-I -- Yeah, I'll guess.
-Yeah, get in on this.
-I'll get in on this one.
-Get in on this.
I mean, this is just
riveting stuff.
You've gotta be --
-If you win, we're kicked out
of our house, though.
-That's the problem.
-Last question.
[ Laughter ]
"What is Rob's hidden talent
that not too many people
know about?"
-Ooh!
[ Soft drum plays ]
[ Laughter ]
-And you can't say --
We all know he's a great actor.
Can you sing?
I forget if you can sing.
Maybe you're very athletic?
No, I feel like maybe there's
and artsy -- You know what?
I'm just going to take
a wild guess.
[ Laughter ]
All right, here we go.
Uh, Matthew?
[ Drumroll ]
Wait, "Impressions"?
I was going to say impressions!
-That's a good one, damn it.
-Johnny?
"History buff"!
-He knows his history.
-Rob Lowe?
-Surfing!
[ Laughter ]
-They're all good!
-I was going to say impressions,
too, 'cause he is
a great impressionist.
I thought maybe you paint.
Do you paint?
[ Laughter ]
[ Music plays ]
Do you paint?
-I don't paint.
-[ Laughs ]
You're such a loser!
Why don't you paint?
-What are you good at?
-Guys, we have a tie.
You're both the Best Son.
-Aww!
I like that.
I love the way that works out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Music plays ]
-Matthew and John Owen Lowe,
everybody!
Check out "The Lowe Files"
on the A&E!